this is irrational treasure we must find
the secret to Pacifica Northwest he was
great granddad white silly as well so it
kind of works this is a mystery that
must be solved solved
um what's dry let's drive okay the rest
of this is gonna all be done Nicolas
Cage voice uh I will not do that now
with the voice away I would like to
nominate a series of babies Supreme
Court take off your pants the deep pants
vacation Proclamation alright so the
code in this one was the Latin phrase
for out of many Trembley 2008 Trembley I
think so the yeah president yeah um and
third Esquire yes the silliest president
we ever had which given our presidents
and saying a lot um I wasn't saying I
still think we've had sillier yeah I
love the the ending with the Supreme
Court babies there's like it is a dark
day for America and I'm just in there
like it's still better than cod head
haha see I'd take the babies um so
pretty much the pioneer days going on
gravity falls and Mabel feels bad
because specific of out tears being
silly and she feels really bad so she uh
Pacifica makes fun of for nacho earrings
even though if you look she has earrings
very similar which guy Greg they're
giant purple arrow yeah that they're
giant purple pretty much triangles again
um no arrow heads okay whatever
that's not a perfect triangle okay with
a little they're well rounded they have
a base they weren't you ever in Cub
Scouts or something no Chuck Norris said
I couldn't do um I never listened to
Chuck Norris
ah but it's uh so you have maple says
she doesn't want to feel silly
it wants to be taken seriously so she
tries to she takes off the sweater which
as you said I like it yeah I said
there's like
like who is that like without the
sweater I was like oh my god that's just
like it's not the same character that's
how you know you've got good character
justice I yeah when she put it back on
him like Oh Mabel where did you um and
so they one of the the book says that
there's this conspiracy that the founder
of gravity falls related to Pacifica
actually isn't the founder so Mabel
tries to be serious but through a lot of
her silly actions actually leads to
discovering this conspiracy that a lot
of people who tried to be very serious
can't and it turns out there is an
eighteenth and a half president that was
a cover-up because he was very very
silly and married woodpeckers and so on
and so forth um although I guess that
was just gravity falls in general that
wasn't even a oh yeah I don't think I
think that was just part of the town's
bylaws in the early day I'm something so
um and uh and the two cops who it has
family guy boy the evidence was really
piling up oh yeah
then they only give thought is funny oh
it was it if being delightful was a
crime i you'd be a little rosy i don't
like you offers are we the key and then
when it comes these is like we don't
have any pink balloons up oh then why
did we come here i'm like okay got a
gone vacation together and stuff they're
they're delightful there there are a lot
of losses when the when was loves
lizzing i'll whether the black cap oh i
forget that what he has to when he has
to take a knee like what when they say
there is exert even gotten get for you
sir just being around used laugh yeah
they owe something no something like
that that's like what all their lines
are like it it's very much the lenny and
carl relationship i tell you except they
just gave it no time or blue I don't
write interns and Smithers at this point
what Oh cut Smithers knows I think
they're still like they're either in
denial or they're just so experimenting
you know they're so fascinating where
it's gonna go they're like let's just
let it play out and discover oh but it's
it's a lot of fun to watch yeah
at
you know what I I hope they discover
what it is I want and they're very happy
I I think they're already very happy and
what they'll discover will just make
them happier so um no problem in a brand
new world yes and the make friendship
bracelets it just the image of them on
the train like in the Hawaiian shirt say
goodbye goodbye where are you gonna kill
us what no no no it's okay it's okay
it's okay um so they they discover this
conspiracy and maple feels good because
she had to be silly to do it then she's
like I have nothing to prove I have
proven to myself already and dipper says
oh fuck batshit and goes Ms Fromme I
never Wow
revenge is really underrated that felt
great yet it improves it which again Cal
like the last one it plays with the not
necessarily the moral although I guess
it does a little bit but uh a place with
the delivery of it a touch because it's
like us maple still she obviously had
take the right moral dipper dozen but
what works like that sometimes you let
someone else do your dirty work
yeah so it's but I like that she didn't
need it it's not like you know no no
dipper go do this it's like a loophole
is like no no she's actually very legit
Leah P um and then the president flies
backwards onto a horse and writes him
off backwards and at my very Mabel silly
heavy episode and that's why did you say
Maybelle Mae she's a ship Mabel on to
the Maybelle um Mabel Mabel okay my
bells Vega it's a very mobile heavy
episode which is awesome um honestly I I
like when it's focused I think seeing a
number of episodes I like it best when
it's focused on the mystery of the town
or those or grunkle Stan and Mabel
dipper Zeus so pretty much anyone in the
show no because I'm the glut thing to
mention Wendy and her idiot friends like
whenever the story seems to focus on
them that's
I start to tune out a bit and I'm like
it's still very funny but I'm just like
not as into it like this episode I was
all over in the previous episode I'm
like that was okay
well I think Empire that is because
whatever she's involved it's always Oh
we'll defer to her will you know that
stuff so it's like Oh Kayla stretches
out a little bit more I'm usually not a
fan of those um but you know that they
lead to some good comedy you know and no
I'm not saying it's bad but it's just
even when you have a great show there's
great episodes and good episodes yeah
and the Wendy based episodes seem to be
good and these other episodes seem to be
great no I really I really say the Mabel
centered episode any day oh yeah
particularly if it was like this I do I
do love the one where they go into the
convenience store and it's haunted
though that was good
yeah I I think that that had more of the
mystery element to it like the last one
was just a party
hmm so um but yeah I'm trying to think
of a try thing very stuff for this one
what about the show is how silly it is
yeah it is just uh oh you know why take
some example door dolly said there's
some lion of his days is like you know
the world just doesn't have enough silly
like you just and it's like true it's
like just a show like this just is so
right up my alley and I think that's why
I like Mabel because yeah she's silly
but she did inadvertently end up solving
everything well yeah that's what I was
gonna say I really like the idea they
show you know not just the fun of silly
but kind of the importance of silly you
know silly is very important honking out
of the box is what got them to solve
yeah there is and a lot I would have
listed everything well no that was my
favorite moment she's like look I made a
hat and he's like wow you made a hat
that points to location and I was gonna
burn it yeah we light it on fire that
may be the secret I can call show um no
I like uh and that is a good moral and
that's not someone you see too many
times in kid shows that's like you know
is silly is good you know and they can
actually lead to some great minds a lot
of the great minds you know have these
very silly funny eccentric parts to them
and it can show how useful that is um
and they say very often like if you're
stuck on something whatever it is
no just go relax go for a walk do
something silly watch ash or whatever
and sometimes it'll just come to you and
I think that's a part of is that when
you're silly you're relaxed you know
when you're being goofy and whatever you
know here you're relaxing you think
better way to relax and hey um it lets
you become a congressman yeah apparently
um who can legalize anything yes I'm
legalizing everything heck you realize
if she legalizes everything then
technically twincest is legal
oh you haven't heard of that I'm I have
never heard the term no I can guess what
it is uh type gravity falls twincest and
google and search oh oh I I thought you
were just sick I mean you are but whoa
god that's like the one Mimi saw where
it just shows Wendy shouting why does
everyone rule 30 for me it wasn't me
move isn't there like why is everybody
complaints about my character yet rule
34 is me um but yeah no I type in and
see what you get that well I'm so glad
you discovered that and I discover it in
for my lovely lovely fans discovered it
for our well thank you lovely lovely you
have lovely lovely fans I do
lovely lovely twin ups open open this up
to of a whole new actually it was
preceded not only are they twins but
they're little freaking kids yeah I know
is gonna break up I bet you know what I
promised my fans I was gonna do this to
you this was worth those are your
reaction what is wrong with you internet
even Wendy the more thing is like 50s
that's kind of sick - the more I think
about it it's like one of the funny
thing is no they present like they told
me about this as a warning oh you're
into this show though you're gonna be
really great warning don't look up
twincest like they're like right now we
have to well if they were just like I
don't I'm not looking I don't need to
see that okay the mental image the fact
of this fucking exists is enough baby
they kept to the kept Oreos like you
just oh my god it's so I just
like finally of time I'm like I I come
from an anime background there is
possible there is nothing you can scare
I want we say anime background sounds
like you were raised by anime people or
something like it's no the kind of like
that my god was raised literally by
tentacle so there is nothing nothing
there you talk about our parents that
way what is wrong with you what did this
v-log go so dark right your parents were
in Cthulhu oh my god you were adopted
and the running joke continues but will
it have an end like gravity falls has an
end plot triangles in this episode and
legalization of twincest what is wrong
with you